Marshall goldsmith,
author,
what got you here won't get you there.
Well,
I just wrote a story about this and
Harvard Business Online.
Now I'll give you a few tips on American
Airlines alone.
I have nine point 5 million frequent
flyer miles.
I'm the highest level flyer on united.
I've got a gold card on British air,
Yada,
Yada.
I'm like constantly.
Few tips.
Number One,
forget where you've been and be where
you are.
This is a Buddhist.
One of the worst things you can do when
you travel is focus on what time is it
in Kentucky?
What time is it where I started?
Who Cares?
You're not there.
You're here.
Another guideline is force yourself to
sleep and I find it's very handy.
I wear the little things that put over
my eyes.
I put the blanket over my head,
go to sleep.
I sleep on airplanes.
By the way,
the other one I always use.
Very bizarre.
Looking on a long flight.
I was put the blanket over my head when
I sleep.
What it does is you say,
I speak constantly as a for my job.
Well,
if you fly in an eight hour flight and
you sleep,
you breathe deeply,
that dry air hits the back of your
throat and you get a sore throat.
If you put the blanket over your head,
it holds in your buddy moisture and you
don't get a sore throat.
And you know what?
I found very few people talk to you when
you have the blanket over your head.
In fact sometimes two people sitting
next to you leave.
It's all good,
right?
So you just put the blanket over your
head,
you sleep and then don't drink on the
airplane.
The only time I drank as if I'm on an
eight hour flight,
I want to sleep.
I have one or two glasses of wine before
I go to bed for a long period of time,
but in general don't drink on the
airplane exercise when you get off the
plane if you can.
And the other thing is just make peace
with what is.
And also I eat before I get on the
plane.
I don't eat on the plate.
If you get on the plane,
two or three hours gets blown while
they're slowly bringing food back and
forth and you have this sort of used
plate sitting in front of you there for
a half hour,
you know,
and the airport's.
Everybody complains about flight number
one.
Almost always flown more than me.
How many days have I missed because of
flying in 30 years one.
So the system works better than people
like to give it credit for.
I,
I almost always get to where I'm going.
Right?
So the system actually works.
People complain about the food,
don't eat it,
don't eat the food and always good make
you didn't cost that much.
And the one thing that has gotten better
is the food at the airport,
put it.
The airport says 20 times better than it
was.
I flew 30 years ago.
The food was hideous.
Thirty years ago.
You had no choice.
It was overpriced.
Much better today.
So make the best of it.
I think a lot of it is just your
attitude.
Be where you are and make peace.
If you don't want to travel,
don't travel.
If you're going to travel,
don't whine about it.
Oh,
the other thing is,
I have to say I annoyed by very little
in life.
One thing I do find it even annoys me is
people being rude to flight attendants.
The plane is like or yelling at the
flight attendant.
It's not the flight attendants fault.
They can't make the plane take off,
you know,
shut up.
Just sit there and you know,
read a book,
bring a book.
That's another good thing.
Brings something you want to read.
Bring a book,
sit there and make peace.
It is what it is.
You don't have to annoy everyone around.
You just shut up,
right?
Just go with it and if you do that,
it tends to work a lot better.
I went to Africa.
One thing,
it helps me in a very odd way.
In 1984,
I went to Africa with the American Red
Cross famine relief campaign and I
watched a lot of people starve to death
and I came home.
You know what I said,
don't complain because the airplane's
late.
There are people out there starving to
death.
Don't complain because the airplanes
late every,
it sounds kind of trivial,
but every time I get on an airplane,
you know what I think,
who cares?
How serious is this?
I'm not starving to death.
I'm not going to die here.
Why am I wasting my life getting angry
about this stuff you can't control it.
Make peace with.
Well,
I'll tell you,
there's one way in my field,
it's helped a lot and I've got a good
friend named cal wick has put together
this followup system.
A lot of what I do in coaching is
followup.
They've got some really great electronic
followup systems that people have
developed up.
Who did you talk to?
What did you learn?
What are you going to do about it?
Are these ongoing sense of reminders and
follow up and it works really,
really well if people do it,
and again,
it's a really positive use of technology
to help people get better.
Well,
I mean,
I think new technology is part of life
and one of the keys for being the leader
of the future is technological savvy.
Most of what I learned is it goes back
to basic Buddhist philosophy of accept
what is the past is the past.
We can all have these little nostalgic
Lonnie longings for the past,
but you know what?
It's gone now.
I have a 61 corvette,
which is a beautiful car,
just beautiful white with a red coat,
you know,
very spiffy looking.
Everybody talks about how great the cars
were in the past though they weren't.
They were awful.
They broke down all the time.
Their breaks were terrible.
You can buy a $12,000
car today.
It's far better than any car you could
have bought the past.
We just have these memories about the
past as if it were this wonderful time.
Well,
the past people forget.
We used to have things like racism and
sexism and we had a lot of things in a
password.
Not so wonderful that today they are
much better now.
Those kinds of things are much better
than they used to be.
So I think the main thing is make peace
with what is.
And you are where you are.
So you're here now.
So now we have lots of technology,
so make peace with lots of technology.
On the other hand,
to me,
what's not an acceptable option is to
say,
well,
I don't like that stuff.
That stuff is part of life.
Yeah,
that's fast past.
I was part of life.
You could make peace.
You know,
it's there.
Everybody's using it.
You've got to learn how to use
technology or else you're just lost.